الساعات الاولى من هذا اليوم او قبل بدايه
سريان الهدنه التي دخلت حيزه تنفيذ بالفعل
عند تمام الساعه السادسه صباحا بتوقيت
الخرطوم هذه الهدنه حاولنا ان نرصد
الشوارع وطبيعه الحياه خلال هذه الهدنه في
بدايتها وفي ساعات الاولى الان نحن الان
في واحد من اكبر واهم شوارع الخرطوم وهو
شارع المطار هذا هو مركز عفراء للتسوق
واحد من اكبر واهم مراكز التسوق في
الخرطوم طبعا كان واحدا من بؤره التوتر
وكذلك شهدت هذه المنطقه عموما يعني هذه
المنطقه عموما شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه ما بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع هذا
المركز الذي تحول بعضه الى رماد بشكل كامل
الاشتباكات هنا تبدو واضحه طبعا على هذا
المركز وغيره من الاماكن التي بدت في غايه
الخراب سباق كان في هذا المكان او كذلك
ربما في اماكن اخرى يعني خلال وصولنا الى
هذا المكان رصدنا بالعين طبيعه الشوارع
وطبيعه الحال التجاريه وخلو الشوارع طبعا
كذلك ايضا من السيارات حركه السيارات تبدو
منعدمه تماما طبعا اغلب الاسر واغلب الاسر
رحلت من اماكنها طبعا هذه تاثيرات القصف
قطع
لاسلحه تتناثر هنا وهناك وكذلك حريق ورماد
طالع هذا المكان كثير من الاماكن ايضا
والشوارع طوا الحريق وصالها الدمار بشكل
يبدو واضحا للعين حتى وصلنا الى هذا
المكان